All right guys, so here's another variation to this model that you can use, okay?
So everything the same, right? You have your external taken out your drawn liquidity is this fair value gap now on the one-hour time frame
Let's say you get a market structure shift, but you don't have a clean PD array
You don't have a fair value gap here. You don't have a clean auto block here, right?
What you can do is you have to wait for an ABC D set up to form here. So a
BCD, right?
Even if you don't want to take your trade from let's say the fair value gap you can look for this pattern here
So ABCD once you have the ABCD price takes out this high over here
So now we zoom in onto the five-minute time frame. This is when price takes out this level, right?
So we want to mark out this low, right?
And we want to scout out the market maker consolidation from this move right here, right to the to here. So
This right here is
Consolidation then we get second accumulation, right?
So now when price takes out the high we look for a market structure shift on the five-minute time frame, right?
From here onwards when you get a market structure shift what you can do is look for a second distribution entry model, right?
You can do that or you can just simply enter from the fair value gap that forms here or the auto block
Okay, so the continuation is mostly gonna happen from
8 a.m.
tail
then 30
okay, so look for a continuation set up in between these times and
Remember guys
Let's say that there is a news on the same day and your setup forms before the news. You don't have to take that setup
You have to in most cases wait for the news to be over and then you can look for the setups
Okay, especially when you are trading on the five-minute time frame because using this
Combination daily early in five minute. We're gonna be taking trades on the five minute
So we have to trade after the news is over
Not before that, okay
So this is the continuation pattern, right? You get a purge ABCD
Right, then you wait for a market structure shift on the five minute time frame
So the ABCD occurs on the one hour
once that happens you mark out the
move, right that is where you want to scout out the market maker model that has consolidation like that and
And
You dropped on to five minute get a market structure shift take your entry mitigation blocks boom boom boom boom boom
That is your take profit level
So
Yeah, guys that's pretty much about it
I'm gonna give you guys some examples and then we'll move on to the last couple of lectures